hello les gens et oui cette année
Mohamed ça le département de La Réunion
aux côtés des Réunionnais que les lois
des auxiltilles une fête de la musique
spéciale 2 fêtes de la musique et oui ça
sera le 21 juin à Paris et le 24 juin à
Lyon parce que le thème c'est n'oublie
pas n'oublie pas où ça nous sort
effectivement n'oublie pas un créole que
les noix des autres cils avec entre
autres
animations qui sera aussi avec moi à
côté pour animer et prenez des artistes
tels que James futur crew tes enfants
d'ados
pour que vous êtes tout amuse mais c'est
même pas obligé
parce que le département de La Réunion
elle est là au côté de réunionnais.bon
l'ambiance donc de Data retenir le
mercredi 21 juin à Paris et le samedi 24
juin à Lyon mais quand
[Musique]